in 1987 the new york times front page
read
breakthrough in problem solving the
breakthrough here
refers to the invention of the interior
points method
an efficient algorithm for convex
optimization
and here you might wonder what is convex
optimization
and what is so important about it that
the headline refers to it as
problem solving and what makes the
discovery of this new algorithm
for solving convex optimization problems
so special
that it's made the headline of a journal
like the new york times
if you are asking yourselves these
questions you are in luck because this
is exactly
the topic of this video series
this series is broken into three parts
part one is a short introduction to the
active field of mathematics
that is optimization and some of its
applications
in part two we will dive deeper into the
topic of convex optimization
and we will introduce a fascinating
related concept
that is the principle of duality
the third and last part has a more
algorithmic component
there we will finally have all the
necessary ingredients
to overview the interior points method
for convex optimization
[Music]
as a bonus if you stick around until the
end
you will know what this ocean animation
represents and how it relates to the
topic of optimization
this video series is intended for anyone
who is curious about mathematics
and its applications it should be
accessible to a
wide range of audiences since it does
not require any specific background
beyond basic linear algebra and basic
calculus
it is suited for math and computer
science students
who want to know more about optimization
[Music]
but also researchers or engineers who
might have heard of optimization before
and want to know what they can gain from
it or how they can use it
in their own work or research projects
let me point out here that these videos
represent my
personal take on the topic of convex
optimization
so it might be a little different from
more traditional expositions that you
might find elsewhere
and it is by no means exhaustive but my
goal here is
to give a self-contained presentation
that is crisp
visual and focuses on building intuition
without getting bogged down with too
much mathematical details
which you can always check later if
needed
and with that being said it's time to
grab some coffee because we're about to
get started
before we talk about convex optimization
let's take a step back and
first define optimization what do we
mean when we
refer to some problem as an optimization
problem
well you have an optimization problem
whenever you are faced with a bunch of
options that you can choose from
where each option has a cost associated
with it
and your job is to make the optimal
choice or in other words
you need to pick the option with the
smallest possible cost
note that sometimes in optimization
there are situations where
we want to pick the option which
maximizes some given metric
often referred to as a reward rather
than minimize the cost
without cause of generality we can
simply multiply the reward
by -1 and convert a maximization problem
to a minimization one so for the rest of
this video
i'm going to follow a cost minimization
convention
note also that in this toy example there
are only 6
options in general however the number of
options could be huge
or even infinite a typical example where
the number of options is infinite is
when you try to pick a real number x
from the continuum of all real numbers
that minimizes some given function f
say differently you try to pick a scalar
x
that we refer to as a decision variable
such that
f of x is as small as possible
here x is a one-dimensional scale but it
could also be multi-dimensional
for example x could be a two-dimensional
vector x1 x2
a three-dimensional vector x1 x2 x3 etc
more formally
an optimization problem is given by
three ingredients
the first ingredient is a set where our
decision variable lives
often this is simply rn the
second ingredient is a cost function f
that we want to minimize
this function maps the set where our
decision variable lives
to r this function is sometimes known as
the objective function
the third and final ingredients are
constraints on the decision variable
constraints come in the form of equality
constraints
and inequality constraints
the equality and inequality constraints
together define what is known as the
feasible set or the set of possibilities
where you can pick
the decision variable x from
to recap optimization problems are often
written in this form
let us right away see some examples when
the cost function
f is a linear function and when the
functions
h i and gj that define the constraints
are
linear functions as well then we have
what is known as a
linear program linear programs are among
the problems that we understand the best
and as we will see later on it is
essential to understand what happens in
the simpler
and maybe idealistic linear word before
we move on
to more complicated nonlinear problems
[Music]
so in the next three minutes or so let
us try to build some geometric intuition
about linear programs to visualize
linear programs geometrically
we need to first understand how to
visualize linear functions
there are essentially two ways we could
go about visualizing
a linear function like this one either
we represent it with a hyperplane with
equation f of x equals zero
or with the vector c that is normal to
this hyperplane
the hyperplane representation is useful
for visualizing where the linear
function f
takes some given value like maybe f of x
equals
0 1 or 2. on the other hand
the vector representation is useful for
understanding the direction
that increases or decreases this linear
function
[Music]
for linear cost functions we prefer the
vector representation
the reason is that in the absence of
constraints and
in order to minimize a cost function f
what you need to do is simply move along
the vector minus c
as much as possible easy enough
so now let us see how to visualize
linear constraints
for linear functions that define linear
constraints
we prefer the hyperplane representation
a hyperplane divides the space in three
regions
a positive half space a negative valve
space
and a null region or the hyperplane
itself
now if you think of the whole space
where your decision variable lives as
this cube
then a linear constraint for example an
inequality constraint
will cut off a part of the cube and as
you add
more and more linear constraints more
and more parts of the cube
are going to be cut off and the region
of the space that we are left with
is our feasible region
moving on an optimization problem that
might be familiar to you
is linear regression or the least
squares problem
here we try to model the relationship
between
inputs a and outputs b and more
specifically
we try to fit a linear model so
our decision variable is a vector of
weight our objective function
measures the error in our linear model
and note that the objective function is
not a linear function but rather
a quadratic function and our constraints
are
well there aren't any constraints in
this example
there exists quite few variations of
this problem
for example we could replace the linear
model with a
more complicated function like a neural
network
in that case the regression problem
becomes a considerably harder problem
and this should already give you a hint
that some optimization problems
are easier to handle than others a third
example of
optimization problems i want to show you
is portfolio optimization
from the field of finance in portfolio
optimization
you are presented with a list of assets
like stocks
and your job is to pick which assets and
how much of each asset
you should buy here your objective is to
maximize returns and your constraints
are
that maybe you have a fixed budget that
you cannot exceed
and maybe you have a cap on the maximum
volatility
allowed for your portfolio
more generally any problem that involves
taking the best decision under
constraints
is an optimization problem engineering
advertising games are just some examples
in conclusion to this first part of this
series
i would like to point out that so far we
have focused on
taking a problem and formulating it as
an optimization problem
we have not yet discussed how you can
actually solve these problems
in fact optimization problems that have
very similar formulations
can require a completely different set
of techniques to solve
and we often need to design specialized
machinery
for each problem separately in the last
couple of decades however
something magical has happened we have
discovered that a
large family of optimization problems
namely
convex optimization problems can be
solved efficiently in a unified manner
once you recognize a given optimization
problem as convex
then you can apply an already
established and mature technology that
people have developed for convex
problems
almost as a black box in the next video
we will discuss convexity in more
details and see what makes this property
so attractive from an optimization point
of view
and in the third and last video we will
peek inside this black box
and uncover some fascinating ideas
behind it
and finally i would like to thank you
personally for making it this far in
this video and
see you next time